[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream I am here with dr.
Heather huiying this is our 30th
livestream is that right that's right is
it fair to say 30th in a row I think so
yeah yeah yeah 30 it's right in a row
well that is that is a remarkable track
record I would say all right we are
facing a world that is moving at an
incredible pace and having skipped a
live stream because it was impossible to
do from the road
we now have even more things that have
transpired in the in the period between
this one in our last live stream we
wanted to start with a couple of
logistics though couple of logistics yep
we wanted to mention the Dark Horse
Clips channel which is now live which
will have clips already has clips from
many of the previous episodes you can
find that at Dark Horse clips there is
no a discord server which you can get
access to as a benefit at either of our
patreon at the $5 an uplevel and we have
something called Dark Horse membership
at my patreon at the $5 an uplevel which
gives you access to a private Q&A one
every month we're gonna have to refigure
the level at which people get to ask
questions because it's been more
successful they were expecting and we
already have too many questions at that
11 dollar level but but we do that on
the last Sunday of the month and I'm
Brett also does conversations at higher
levels on the first Saturdays and
Sundays of every month at his patreon so
those are some things going on and then
evident those conversations have been
spectacular of late I'm I'm thrilled
with what they've they've been doing
they were spectacular before but they
were smaller and then people have joined
in and they've discovered that there's
an ongoing conversation and there's a
lot of enthusiasm so anyway consider
that fabulous and would you like to give
any updates to Unity 2020 yes it's gonna
be slightly vague but I would like you
to deduce from the tone of my voice that
things are moving in an excellent
direction with unity 2020 we are
discovering what Unity 2020 is because
of course it is not a ploy
party right so unity 2020 is moving
rapidly in the right direction of course
what we need is the groundswell what we
have now is a large team of very capable
Patriots who are putting every effort
into this thing and generating amazing
stuff which you will soon see and I
think you will be very pleased at what
it is and then the question is how many
communities that are actually aligned
with unity 2020 that might have been
working on a different part of the
puzzle are going to recognize us as
fellow travelers and join in because the
fact is if we don't solve this stifling
governmental corruption problem that is
managed by the duopoly to prevent
meaningful change if we don't fix that
none of the other things are going to be
fixable
everything else is downstream of that so
really we got to go we got to do it and
the time is now because the problem is
so critical it can't possibly wait
another election cycle okay all right
so where should we begin should we begin
with a discussion of where we are with
respect to kovat yeah all right kovat so
the big thing I'm seeing very frequently
is people are talking about well cases
are skyrocketing again which we should
talk about but the case fatality rate is
actually flat or down um which is
interesting and I think we should talk
about what the meaning is in one sense I
don't understand why the surprises
anybody we botched the lockdown and
having botched to lock down the second
wave was absolutely predictable and many
of us predicted it so let's just say I
think probably all the viewers and
listeners will understand this but when
we are saying we in this case we're
talking very much as as American as
American citizens you have the United
States of America not across for the
most part the rest of America and
certainly not across the rest of the
world the United States uniquely [ __ ]
this one up really bad yeah really bad
and in some sense worst of all possible
worlds because what we did was we went
maybe 70% of the way to in effect
locked down which caused everybody to
grow thoroughly tired of it and many
people to rebel against it without
getting much of the benefit at all just
enough to destroy large sectors of the
economy to impinge on everyone's mental
health many people's physical health and
to make everyone so exhausted with the
saying that it is at least one for sure
of the factors that led to the protests
that then became riots in the streets
starting the beginning of June yeah and
it also in maybe you could argue that
this is actually a positive thing but it
revealed the double standard that exists
inside our sense making apparatus where
everybody was demon ated demonizing one
set of protesters and giving another set
of protesters a pass for for being out
there and not social distancing now of
course we have to put this in context
those protests occurred outdoors
outdoors appears to be relatively safe
for the moment
we have predicted that that will
decrease over time but for the moment
outdoor seems to be a safe environment
now of course as we've talked about
before we don't know if it's safe during
the day because of UV light or safe all
the time due to the volume and air flow
and therefore never crossing the
threshold of viral load that makes
people sick well I think we know we
actually pretty well know that both of
those things are protective do explain
part of why it is so much safer as to
almost be actually completely safe to be
outdoors during the pandemic that
increased airflow because density of
viral load is completely predictive of
whether or not you can infect it and
also of how sick you get once you do get
infected both of those things and also
it's true that sunlight does destroy
this particular virus as it does many
others so and so we would expect there
will be some less protective effects of
being outdoors at night but that those
effects will certainly not disappear
entirely because I don't I don't have a
sense of of those two factors and I'm
sure there are more but of those two
factors basically increased air flow
being outside and sunlight being outside
which of those you know if I had to put
percentages to how important they are I
don't honestly know well here I'm gonna
do my famous English to English
translation service Wow
that's seriously my job right that's
also your famous English English
translation service so in this case what
I would argue is that we have a model
and we should all be building models
based on what we understand and our
models were really cruddy at the
beginning of kovat and we were all so
worried about washing our hands and
touching surfaces which is important but
it turns out for this particular virus
it's not nearly where the game is the
game is all in this other realm or
almost all the the key though is for
reasons that are yet to be fully
articulated you have to cross some
threshold of the number of viral
particles that you encounter immune
systems with a nonspecific response seem
to be able to deal with some number of
these things and so a conversation of a
minute or two even with a sick person is
unlikely to cross that threshold a
five-minute conversation is much more
likely to a five-minute conversation in
an enclosed space that captures all of
those particles so they're all unable to
diffuse a way makes it even worse and if
you're outside you got to think you've
got a bucket that you're filling with
viral particles and if you cross the top
of the bucket you get sick but the
bucket is being emptied by the UV light
which is killing viral particles at some
rapes of the bucket and by the air flow
well the air flow means that the bucket
isn't filling very fast because they're
diffusing away and they're also dying
right the UV light is killing them and
so those two things are removing these
things yeah it's the concentrating
environments that make you much more
likely to get sick and it's the
environments that dispel or kill these
things that make it much less likely for
you to catch and people are both so poor
at understanding these nuances and being
educated so badly by the media and by
scientists that for the most part we are
falling into as I've been saying since
almost the beginning these these tribes
these you know starbella stages and
stages without and so you know we see
now when we when we when we go out that
there are people wearing masks and you
know in the state of Oregon where we
live it is now mandated to wear masks
inside and an outside and there's a new
twist to this as of yesterday but
outside mostly people are not wearing
masks which is a legitimate move and yet
you can also see in the eyes of people
that they are judge
you and assuming that if you're not
wearing a mask you're one of those
people who doesn't ever want to wear
masks and that's not to say that any of
us want to be wearing masks but
understanding the necessity of wearing
masks when you're inside with strangers
is very different from imagining that
mask wearing every time you leave your
home is necessary so let me say that on
a next door which is you know this this
app it will be familiar to many people
it's the sort of neighborhood connection
device just yesterday we had someone in
our neighborhood post with regard to a
several hundred acre park that's very
dear us I walked in the state park today
and I was disappointed that fifty
percent of people were not wearing a
face covering if people can't or won't
wear a face mask she wrote they should
not use trails it is selfish and
reckless to not wear a face covering on
a trail please walk on neighborhood
streets instead now I responded and for
the first time ever our next-door you
know carefully and respectfully and and
got many thanks for it and the original
post has since been pulled down but you
know again this points to the lack of
nuance in someone's understanding and
one of the things I said in response to
her was we we should not be imposing
rules that are neutral or even unhealthy
for people certainly unhealthy for
people with you know everyone is
suffering some mental health effects
from this you know months long lockdown
now and some people with physical
problems are going to be impaired if
they have to wear masks will not
therefore go outside if they have to
wear masks to do so and will be further
impaired as a result of that and
imposing bad rules on people is going to
make many good people less likely to
follow all rules which includes not just
the bad ones but the good ones as well
that is the opposite of what we want I
totally agree with this and I am
experiencing I probably experienced it a
little bit less because my version of a
mask it's some sort of signal it's still
not wearing it results in people even
when I know that my model is quite good
and it's actually based on data in as
much as we have that yeah there is a
sense of like oh you're one of those
anti mask people and and let me just
remind people who have been tuning and
more recently that we started these live
streams on March
20 forests and our very first one we
talked about mass this is before the who
this is before the Surgeon General had
said Oh oops sorry our bad that was
actually a political moved on a
scientific one it turns out masks are
useful after all we just have a shortage
so we were advocating for this before
the mainstream everybody's throw masks
it's us but but I think you know I
really want to emphasize what you just
said it I've landed in exactly the same
place which is that there is a missing
category here which is okay that
person's anti-mask they're not wearing a
mask even in close quarters okay I do
think that there's some shame that
belongs there unless there's a very good
reason that they're not wearing it right
and then there's the pro mask people who
are now broadcasting that there are pro
masks in circumstances where you should
take a break and you should not be
wearing your mask because you need a
break and then there's a third category
which is people who are operating a high
quality model of the infectious problem
here and they are using their masks
accordingly right
and so that category needs not to be
shamed by the always Pro mask people
even if they're gonna be always Pro
masks and you know I've heard at one
point Jill Rogan you know he was in
comedy mode and he was joking about
people who drive around with their masks
and it was funny but I also know I have
especially in the early days of this
driven around with my mask not because I
was afraid in the car alone that I was
gonna get an infection or that it was
going to blow in the window but because
before we understood that so much of
this is airborne and it's not really
about surfaces there was a question
about touching your mask in order to
tickle it up and to and take it down and
so you know if you had two stops that
were close together or if your mask is
comfortable enough then the point is
though you just leave it up it's not
that much of an imposition so somebody
was a sophisticated model should not be
shamed by anybody yeah so and yet here
we have in Oregon where in indoor masks
use in any public space is required as
of I don't know a week or two ago and as
of well I think it might be tomorrow but
the order came down yesterday wearing
masks outdoors is required by law at
risk of fine
if you cannot socially distance by six
feet now there's a lot in that
of course if you cannot socially
distance by six feet but you know to
this to this woman's concern about
people going out into nature and hiking
several miles without a mask on trails
where they may at some point cross paths
with someone else no you should not have
to wear a mask then you should not have
to be wearing a mask while you're hiking
several miles in a hundred and hundreds
of acres State Park right absolutely it
should not be there claimant you should
have one with you force point you know
at this point unfortunately it's become
a thing that everyone needs to be
carrying with them your key you know an
ID probably is some method of payment
and post everyone has their damn phone
on them but mask is one of those things
you need to have with you if you're
going out into public but do you have to
have it on your face when you're when
you're outside for the most part no you
should not and I worry that this new
order from the governor of Oregon
suggests a creep towards anytime you
leave your home you've got to wear a
mask right which is going to then send
the you know already huge mental health
crisis that is looming and relatively
small I think yet physical health crisis
that is looming that is going to tip
that into a giant physical health crisis
because lots of people who are still
able to run and bike and play tennis and
hike won't do so if they're if they have
to wear a mask they may not be able to
it may just be the thing that pivots
them from okay I'm gonna get over myself
my activation but you know I'm and I'm
gonna do it too I'm just gonna stay how
many chips right it's going to be the
thing well it's a difference and a damn
clock is ticking
yeah right it's time if you're gonna
hike you're gonna bike this is the
moment right we've got a limited number
of months to do this and the kicker here
is that the vitamin D connection
suggests actually you better make
vitamin D while the Sun shines
right which means if you're being held
back by anything now
the cost is later what does the cost
come in terms of kovat risk right are
you gonna get it and how bad is it going
to be so that you want to build up in
the bank vitamin D so that when you are
faced with winter you're in much
healthier condition from the point of
view of resisting and infection so we
got to get this we got to get this
dialed in and we just don't have it
right we're really screwing up the
there's just too much rule of thumb
there's too much rule of thumb and
there's too much politicizing of it
right it's B it's become a political
issue and we definitely have president
Trump to thank for that to a large
degree you know someone who who goes
into public and refuses to wear a mask
even when everyone else around him is is
doing so which happened at least a few
times in mayor if I remember correctly
creates a model for his supporters it
says if you know something like if
you're a real man you don't wear a mask
well sorry know the virus doesn't care
what your political position is as we've
said many times before yes and then
there's the next phase which is that for
a long time this intentional conflation
with flu right
this is flu like maybe it's a little
worse than the flu maybe it's worse than
the flu for people who are very old no
no no no this is a desperate
misunderstanding of the virus we face
and I was going to encourage people he's
like you want to put up that subreddit
that I gave you
I happened I didn't know the subreddit
existed although in retrospect I should
have thought that it might this is a
subreddit of people who have tested
positive you want to scroll down a
little bit let's see
keep going stop up a little bit okay
here's one of many many horror stories
right I'm only 21 and I don't think I'm
gonna make it now here's what you will
find if you search this and this is
beginning to be dealt with in the
mainstream press as well not the not the
super big papers but the press is
beginning to catch on to the fact that
there is a lot of life being lost in
people who recover right that the point
is you get back from the flu and
actually I would argue that you probably
have knocked some of your longevity off
but you recover more or less fully from
the flu people are dealing months out
with the most terrible mysterious kinds
of symptoms because as they describe it
in this form accurately this is a virus
that attacks
vital organs right it attacks your
circulatory system it creates blood
clots so the point is a list of symptoms
is is huge and the ongoing hazard to you
is also very large we've known for
months there have been stories of
respiratory reduced function after
recovery from kovat but the cognitive
function being less in many you know I
haven't I have not seen the scientific
paper that there relates this yet but
many journalistic accounts and and other
anecdotal accounts the people who say
there they have they have brain fog
they're unable to find the kind of
thoughts and motivation that they are
accustomed to having and that they had
before they were infected now of course
some of that with regard to motivation
you met many of us I would say all of us
have have been affected by lockdown and
you cannot predict in advance what what
that will do
but people reporting that post recovery
they don't have the same brain they
recognized from before tells us exactly
as you said and as we said back and you
know one of the episodes one through
eighteen when we were largely focusing
on this that just looking at deaths is a
really reductionist way to assess what
the damage from this virus is yes it's
it misses it because the point is if you
have a decade or two knocked off your
life by virtue of the damage done to
your internal organs you want to count
that the fact that you didn't die in the
hospital is is not the sum total of the
story so let's talk a little bit about
why people are dying less and why I
would say if we didn't explicitly
predict it it wasn't it was implicitly
predicted by many of the things we said
the fact is you have a brand-new virus
it is spreading like wildfire and
doctors are seeing it in large numbers
right those doctors are fielding it best
they can based on the next nearest
phenomenon that they know and a lot of
it turns out to have been
counterproductive or on an ineffective
and they learned right they may not even
fully understand what they have learned
some hospitals may have learned better
than others but
doctors in contact over the internet
will have exchanged information and they
are getting better at dealing with kovat
patient we highlighted early on in late
March and mid early to mid April for
instance some few doctors saying I'm not
sure ventilators is the right way to go
this doesn't look like that kind of
disease why have we why have we
formulated it that way and this this to
your point that it could well be but in
fact care for people with this disease
is simply getting more effective care
for this will get more effective it will
continue to get more effective another
thing that happens is evolutionarily
hosts get less affected by disease now
the evolution that accounts for that is
primarily on the host side the virus may
also have an interest in not damaging
the host so much that it doesn't walk
around and spread it but nonetheless
there's also evolution so in this case
probably there hasn't been enough death
yet to account for this but the idea is
what if you had some fraction of the
population that was spectacular Li
likely to contract and die from this
virus by virtue of some molecular
feature of its cell surface or something
like that then a lot of those people
would have been caught in the first wave
that means that the those of us who
remain are in the category we are more
likely to be in the category of people
who aren't quite that vulnerable so can
I do one of these English English
translations here wonderful yeah so
really just to exactly restate what you
just said but there will be some range
of effects for any pathogen and you know
let's just make up some numbers here
maybe 20% of a population will be
affected very badly and die no matter
what
and another 60% there is some range of
possible effects maybe 20% you know have
almost no no symptoms at all and those
numbers are not reflective of what's
going on with Co but I just made up some
numbers but when when the thing first
starts to when the pathogens first start
state of population everyone in that 20%
who is infected will dock and those
people are then no longer in the
population and so you will see that 20%
shrink and shrink and shrink over time
such that what the original numbers were
will change and therefore the CFR the
case fatality rate will change as well
and will decrease yep so don't be misled
by the CFR dropping thing that we were
being told a more dire story than we
actually have on our hands this is
actually quite dire and if you think
it's not I would encourage you to go to
that subreddit and look at the story
after story of people dealing with
terrible symptoms that you just really
don't want to have to deal with and I
must say even though I think we are
incredibly conscious and vigilant about
this
I even spooked myself reading this stuff
it was like wow do you just not want to
be in these people's shoes and you know
I hate to say that because I don't want
to add to their burden like yeah you
know we're distancing ourselves from
them but wow they are a cautionary tale
and we ought to be thinking very
carefully just as you you and I have
said in some sense we've just have game
theory problem after game theory problem
and one of the game theory problems here
is that you know okay
the u.s. screws up its kovat response
okay the u.s. is now a petri dish in
which kovat is now learning new tricks
and the rest of the world is going to
have to deal with the downstream effects
of our botching the lockdown I mean to
the rest of the world does have to
although it now Americans can't even go
anywhere like there are only a handful
of countries
I don't member maybe it's something
between 10 15 maybe you know a dozen
countries ish where Americans are
allowed to travel at the moment and it's
it's Mexico and it's basically a
smattering of island nations in the
Caribbean you can go to Ecuador with a
14 day quarantine on the other end but
pretty much I think all of Europe all of
Asia all of Africa are off limits and
this is this is new for Americans right
we are we're accustomed be able to go
wherever we want to be it's easy to get
visas if you need visas at all then the
rest of the world has looked at what
we've done and looked at what is
happening now and said nope we rest the
world largely did a far better job than
you did and you and your infection are
not welcome here
right which is scary because you know
there are a lot of things that could
happen going forward one of them is
could be four years out from a vaccine
if a vaccine is even conceivable here
and I do think a vaccine is likely but
you know the the best experts in the
world of vaccines are not hopeful about
one in the next year right
that's not to say it's impossible I have
seen some stuff that's hopeful but
there's also hype and it's very hard to
separate those two things so how long
exactly are we gonna go being unable to
travel you know to the rest of the world
right that's another that's an entirely
different set of cost that we're gonna
start paying and it's going to have
profound economic implications so anyway
and and for those of us for some of us
and it's it's a it's a small effect in
the global list of effects but have
tremendous mental health effects Oh
tremendous mental health effects but
yeah I mean look we're talking about a
world we did not prepare for right and
one in which we cannot travel to other
places there are things that require
travel and so there's a question which
is really okay we just got slapped right
we learned a lesson which is that
bravado stuff was not going to get you
through this by virtue of just you know
bucking up and letting some people die
and you know we'd get to the other end
and herd immunity and all of that we're
facing a renewed nightmare and a renewed
nightmare that we now have in some ways
fewer tools to deal with because we've
already blown one lock down and so yep
whatever we need to do now is less
palatable to us and so what if we had
done you propose this probably first of
May okay most of America had already
been in some form of lockdown for five
or six weeks at that point and you said
that first of May everyone is already
exhausted you said what we need is an
actual full lockdown for six weeks
everywhere that would clobber this virus
and then and then we could actually
reopen well it would clobber it if you
then followed up properly yes okay so if
during those six weeks you were
generating tests
mass-producing tests so that at the end
of lockdown you could do active tests
and trace and actually know who was sick
and who wasn't and not have this
smattering of half-assed test with high
failure rates and not enough of them and
no tracing you know we simply a full
lockdown wouldn't have been sufficient
but we did not have an appropriate
lockdown and even when you said this I
something like May first not here but
you know privately our dinner table
my reaction was people won't do it it's
already too late it's already too late
to convince people and that was now over
two months ago right oh yeah we would
have been long since passed that if if
we had done it then yeah so and this I
mean this is exactly a mirror for
frankly for unity 20/20 just wait until
2024 when things will be what better you
think it'll be better by then so I could
it be better yes it's already too late
but it's only gonna get more too late
yes it's only gonna get more too late is
a I like that formulation I think we did
adopt it because it's clumsiness exactly
reflects the clumsiness of our stupid
situation yeah but yeah the fact is now
we need a real lockdown and there's no
way to do it and well I'm sorry friends
we gotta I hate to say it but I don't
know that we have another choice because
I mean a this sort of bleeds into the
next conversation that we're gonna have
but you know it's it we've got a
question about school I mean doing what
to do about it
upcoming and you know there's nuance
here the very young kids seem unlikely
even if they catch it to transmit it so
there's talk of letting kids in grade
school go back but not high school yeah
they're I've seen some proposals and
these things are changing daily such
that even what I thought I knew
yesterday I can no longer find online
but the the conversations in American
schools seem to be sort of trending
towards there have been very few if any
cases known to be have been transmitted
in elementary school elementary school
children so therefore don't seem to
transmit nor
infected middle schoolers more so high
schoolers more yet and so there have
been proposals to do things like totally
virtual schooling for high schoolers at
least through January 2021 some kind of
hybrid system for middle schoolers you
know two days on every week and then
in-person schooling for elementary
school kids all of which is horrible
not only horrible horrible but to the
extent that we let some schools reopen
we're playing with fire fire that we
shouldn't be playing with right we had
we had choices they are being eliminated
without our asking them to be eliminated
or inviting it and at some level winter
is coming
I mean it just simply is right so I mean
you know I'm speaking as if everybody
lives in the northern hemisphere which
almost everyone does but I know that
there are some holdouts down there in
Australia but if you're in New Zealand
well done I should say well done good
planning on you yeah well done no no not
the people who had chose to live there I
mean the political structure that that
demolished Cove at 19 in New Zealand oh
well it was not excellent planning for
everybody on the the islands to be there
and it was good planning of them to use
effective governance to me do you think
you're giving the Kiwis more credit than
they deserve all right now you're the
one who's gonna get cancelled it's fine
because I call them Kiwis Janice we have
a new zealand friend she called yourself
a Kiwi yeah all right but so here's the
thing you're gonna start playing this
game with schools right eh not everybody
in those schools even the grade schools
is a kid right B okay new petri dish we
got kids can the virus figure out how to
infect the kids right now again this
just occurs to me off the top of my head
but I think a lot of what's going on
with this virus would be well explained
if it had leaked from a laboratory that
was using let's say human tissues right
human tissues that have been engineered
not to hit their hayflick limits that
means special human tissues like tumor
tissues right that have dysregulation of
their epigenetic nature which means that
the virus would be you know
chaotic set of cells and it would be
learning how to infect different organs
because even if you took a lung cancer
tissue it might be expressing epigenetic
phenomena from other tissues like liver
so one of the things that might be true
is you know whose tumors you don't tend
to see in laboratories as experimental
material I got this one
do ya children children all right
goodness yeah so I mean look I don't
know how far this goes but let's just
say one possibility is it's a consistent
it doesn't transmit outdoors because
laboratories are indoors it doesn't
transmit to children because the tissues
in question tend to be adult tissues it
tends to be you know capable of jumping
lots of boundaries because that's what
you would train it do and as in a cereal
passage experiment the sounds
verification ax stand we would want to
you know to test all of these but these
are predictions from the idea that this
is a lab there this was lab Jenner they
are subsidiary hypotheses that the the
nature of the epidemiology and the
symptomatology is the result of training
a virus in a lab both intentionally and
inadvertently because of the way lab
techniques work so for those of you who
are still thinking maybe it doesn't
matter where it came from because we've
still got to deal with it know it
matters a lot where it came from it's
going to evolve differently if it if it
jumped from a bat or a Pangolin that it
was than if it was created especially
from tumor tissues that don't have
hayflick limit switch you mentioned that
being cells that do not have an endpoint
that it could just keep replicating
indefinitely those those cells will act
differently and therefore viruses that
can be transmitted via those cells will
act differently than any other naturally
occurring virus yep and the fact is even
if this came from the wild if it came
directly from a bat somehow by some
means we do not know we don't know that
it did yet and until we know that it did
you cannot shut down these hypotheses
that suggests this may be a central
player in the epidemiology and the other
phenomenology associated with this virus
so we need to know and if what we prove
is that actually through some
we don't get it came directly from a bat
great that would be really positive um
but it's not looking likely I gotta tell
you yeah so what do we do is that where
we're going next well I think more to
say about school yeah quite quite a bit
actually um so our friend Keiko kowambe
who's online as on Twitter as Keiko and
Boston for those who are looking for a
follow who she just does extraordinary
research and unexpected things yeah I'm
awesome [ __ ] she she is she is amazing
so it's Keiko in Boston so she pointed
us to this egregious action that just
happened in Michigan where even though
Governor Whitmer I think it is in
Michigan had declared that what
probation violations would not result in
jail time something like this she had
declared something basically to give a
break to both people and potentially the
system during coab in 19 despite that a
15 year old girl in Michigan who has
among other things an IEP an
individualized education plan and a
history of mood disorders and a
difficult relationship with her mother
who was the only parent in the household
but a loving one didn't do her homework
when school transitioned to online in
March she didn't do her homework Wow and
she was sent to juvenile detention as a
result not doing her homework was a
violation of her probation the judge
declared so Keiko points out in a thread
about this and there's a story in
ProPublica public Republica ProPublica
let's go public
okay so ProPublica has a stereo which
will link to in the description or the
pend comment on this but Keiko roat's
points out that the judge wrote in her
decision that grace the fifteen-year-old
in question quote is a threat community
as original charge was assault and theft
that assault and theft being a skirmish
with her mother in which both parties
have since apologized so she was deemed
a threat to the community for not doing
her homework how is this justice Keiko
asks which if you know of course it's
not justice and more to the point though
this so points to the failure virtual
schooling and a
of what school is this is it imagines
this virtual classroom garbage imagines
that school was about sitting in
classrooms doing rote tasks and
memorization that's not education it's
not education people we have a lot to
say about this in general and in the
book that we're writing but I'd love to
read two pages from john taylor gatto
weapons of mass instruction a 2009 book
before you do that I have a technical
question is there a statute of
limitations on having done your homework
because I'm a it's possible I missed
some assignments yeah yeah and I think
both of our children are in trouble too
I mean I'm gonna you're gonna have to
come to me for your your bail guys okay
so just just a couple of pages I this
book is extraordinary he's this this guy
john taylor gatto one let's see i did
not go back and think about his
biography he's he's since died but he
won I think New York State's Teacher of
the Year award at least once and he was
a teacher for decades in the New York
public school system and he railed
against the the destruction of children
through schooling they're both but all
of those things are true and he says
here let me just one more thing about
the book though I recommend this book
very very highly he does unfortunately
like Robyn D'Angelo in white fragility
misunderstand like many good liberals
with no background in science and
specifically no background in
evolutionary thinking conflate social
Darwinism with an evolutionary
understanding of human behavior so
there's that's a bit irritating in the
beginning of the book if you do read his
sort of history of compulsory education
but other than that I find a little to
disagree with here so he says let me
tell you a little bit about fat Stanley
whose path crossed mine when he was 13
Stanley onek only came to class one or
two days a month and I knew that sooner
or later he would be caught in the
truancy net and prosecuted I'd like
Stanley not least because he never
whined when other kids bothered him
because he was fat he simply punched
them so hard in the head nobody ever
bothered Stanley a second time I hope to
spare him the grim experience of
becoming a social service case
as grace became a social service case so
I asked him one day what he did on all
those absences what he said changed my
life I never saw school the same way
after Stanley spoke it seems Stanley had
five outs and uncles all in business for
themselves before the age of twenty-one
his aim was to follow in their footsteps
even at 13 he had been made aware of
times winged chariot hurrying near that
he had only eight years to make the
miracle of an independent livelihood one
of the relatives was a florist when a
builder of unfinished furniture when a
deli owner wanted a little restaurant
one owned a delivery service
Stanley cut school to work without pay
for each of these relatives bartering
labor in exchange for learning the
businesses and a whole lot more working
in the company of men and women who
cared for him much more than any
professional stranger would have it was
a better educational package than
whatever he missed cutting school hands
down as he put it to me man-to-man quote
this way I get a chance to see on the
different businesses work you tell me
what books I have to read and I'll read
them but I don't have time to waste in
school unless I want to end up like you
working for somebody else when I heard
that I couldn't keep him locked up in
good conscience besides his mother
agreed with Stanley so I began to cover
for him
logging him present when he was marking
floral bouquets or building furniture
none of his other teachers ever asked I
think they were glad to be rid of him to
illustrate the powerful energies at work
under his fat deceptively cheerful
exterior Stanley crossed his T's with a
pointed spear formation on a simple line
right then and there I adapted his T
crosses my own to remind me what I
learned from a truant that day a big
secret of bulk process schooling is that
is that it doesn't teach the way
children learn a bigger secret is that
it isn't supposed to teach self
direction at all Stanley style is
verboten
school is about learning to wait your
turn however long it takes to come if
ever and how to submit with a show of
enthusiasm to the judgment of strangers
even if they are wrong even if your
enthusiasm is phony school is the first
impression we get of organized society
and its relentless need to rank everyone
on a scale of winners and losers like
most first impressions the real thing
school teaches about your place in the
social order lasts a lifetime for most
of us work in classrooms isn't important
work it fails to speak to real needs
pressing on the young it doesn't answer
burning questions which day-to-day
experience pushes upon young minds
problems encountered outside school
walls are treated as peripheral
when in truth they are always central
when that effect of making work abstract
subject centered external to individual
longings and fears experiences and
questions is to render students of this
enforced irrelevance listless and
indifferent the causes for sluggishness
in the young have been well understood
for a long time I'm tempted to say
forever growth and self mastery are
reserved for those who vigorously
self-direct like Stanley planning doing
creating reflecting freely associating
taking chances punching the lights out
on your tormentors but this is the
precise of the agenda school except to
prevent think of school as a
conditioning laboratory drilling
naturally unique one-of-a-kind
individuals to respond is a mass to
accept continual on we envy and limited
competence as only natural parts of the
human condition
the official economy we have constructed
demands constantly renewed supplies of
leveled spiritless passive anxious
friendless family less people who can be
scrapped and replaced endlessly and who
will perform at maximum efficiency until
their own time comes to be scrapped
people who think the difference between
Coke and Pepsi or round hamburgers
versus square ones our subjects worthy
of argument reminds me of George Carlin
saying that the purpose of school was to
make you just smart enough to operate
the machines yeah there's a lot I can't
I mean you know how much I resonate with
with that I will say in my case the
teachers and professors who figured out
a way to cover for me and break the
rules for me we're the ones that were
the whole reason I was able to get
through school I mean and you know in
the end my advisor dick Alexander was
the ultimate one of these so one day I I
had to get a signature of his I went out
to the ranch that he lived on fine it
was it was a working farm yeah right he
would bail his own hay and all this
stuff and I biked out there was a long
way I biked out there with my form to
say that I had had a committee meeting
this year which I hadn't and of course
he hadn't I biked out there and I got
off my bike and I walked up to the fence
of the paddock and he
over on his horse and it was an old guy
already yeah yeah he was at least in the
70s yep and I said I need your signature
dick and he says oh what's this for my I
said it says I had a committee meeting
this year and he said is this the
meeting I mean that was classic yep but
anyway you know less people
misunderstand the story it's not that
you weren't constantly engaging with him
and with your peers our colleagues and
the other faculty and all of us you just
you didn't you didn't do it
by for him you didn't do it formulaic
Lee I couldn't do it as you were
supposed to I didn't do it as I was
supposed to I didn't even know you know
my dissertation didn't end up on the
topic I was supposed to be working on
but it did end I know bats at all
important yeah the bats don't show up in
it but um but you know yeah you're right
it's not like I didn't do something
useful it's not like I didn't it just
the the regular rules weren't gonna work
and he knew that he appreciated you know
although he was very good at the rules
in a way that I never could have been he
also just spotted that some people don't
fit them and it's worth bending rules
for those people sometimes so yeah I
will say I mean this is probably not the
place but so this was at University of
Michigan where we both got our PhDs and
you know I had always had a lovely time
in school but I didn't have any biology
background until we met Bob Trevor's
late in college whereas you had been
doing biology since you could walk
basically but had always had a
completely lousy time in school and
basically needed nothing more than to be
left alone by it and so you know we had
very different experiences walking into
that system and I'm you know I I know
I've seen evidence that the University
of Michigan which was really the first
public the the first public university
system in the United States that try to
become a premier and you know an elite
university system in it and it did but
they it managed at least that department
of biology then and the University of
Michigan Museum zoology managed to find
ways to laud both of us with our very
different approaches to and backgrounds
and skill sets and all of this you know
we
we both won each of us won different of
their highest awards that they had to
offer for the work that we did there and
you know to their credit that an
institution could see both someone
coming in with almost no background who
needed to self teach and teach on and
learn on the fly but who but who loved
school and someone who had tremendous
background but no ability to play by the
rules and you were always mistaken for
someone who refused to play by the rules
and to some degree that's true but to
some degree it was also just guys I I
just can't do this right the rules don't
make sense yeah you know they do make
sense for this kind of regimented
training thing it's not how you train
people to discover new stuff and so you
know that's I mean the people who broke
the rules on my behalf or bent them it's
not like they weren't frustrated with me
right but they also we're all frustrated
yeah I've begun to detect that pattern
but you know there's a point is look
what is the objective of the exercise
right and you know yeah you know yeah to
discredit but not just decorate know it
says so too many people's credit there
they work constantly asking themselves
what is the point of this exercise and
that is like why how are we having this
conversation about schooling for the
fall fall 2020 in the United States and
no one appears to be asking what is the
point of this exercise right bring
children are not brains in jars they are
not brains in jars we used to hear this
from our idiot colleagues at Evergreen
the faculty colleagues that we had who
basically said I don't care who they are
what they think when they're outside of
school exactly what John Taylor Gatto is
complaining about right oh you know
they're these students are effectively
brains in charge no they're not no one
is we live in meatspace and it's more
than living in meatspace
we we are interfacing with the world
through our senses and through hearing
and smell and and an audition and
through touch and you can't learn
entirely through a screen yeah well
can't do it do you we also just
completely bought the motivational
aspect
so you know the the reason I ended up
the way I did was because school
provides no useful model for motivation
you found self motivation because you
were good at the job in school it wasn't
what you were about but the fact that
you could get a reward from school for
learning things that were totally worth
learning uh-huh
made it functional motivationally for me
I wasn't able to get that so my
experience of school is just constantly
being slapped by it now that wrecks some
people in my case I was able to find
other things that were rewarding enough
to get me to do them that were actually
educational but it didn't fit you know
school kept asking well how are you
doing on the assignment and the answer
was well I'm not doing the assignment
and so the answer is failure dumb track
all that stuff and and and exactly this
right so it's not the school is carrot
and stick model but in your case the
stick didn't kill you and in my case the
carrot wasn't the reward I was looking
for the carrot that I that I got the
actual reward was oh I got whatever the
opposite of dumb tracking is and I got
into classes that were amazing you know
why do I have this pile of books from
tenth grade where I was reading Mao and
Lenin and Marx and Hobbes and Locke and
Rousseau and all of this and you know uh
you know people who were dumb tracked
we're being forced to learn what a
preposition was does it really matter
what a preposition is I never had to do
that yeah and the funny of the fact is
that I got exposed to the great ideas
and terrible ideas of the great thinkers
throughout history while people who were
just as capable were being forced to
rote memorized rules of grammar which of
course you're going to hate school if
that's what you're being exposed to so I
want to give a plug to the black
intellectual roundtable that has just
come out on the Dark Horse podcast and
the reason I want to do that here is
there's a probably the most painful
moment in the whole thing for me maybe
the only painful moment in the whole
thing for me is we were having an
argument about reparations and the panel
did not agree which was expected there
all publicly in different places on on
this issue and my point was I
think reparations is a good idea at all
I don't think that remedy will work but
I think a remedy is justified and I was
arguing that the remedy was investment
in communities and in defense of that
argument I said something about tax
bases telling you what kind of school
you're gonna have if you have a wealthy
neighborhood with a big tax base you'll
have a good school and if you have a
poor neighborhood you'll have a bad one
and I said we know how to make a good
school and I heard myself say it and I
thought what the hell did I just say I
don't believe that we can we know how to
make a better school right we know how
to make a worse school but we don't know
how to make a good school and Camille
foster of course caught me out on this
and he's like I don't think we do know
how to make a good school and it was
like oh man I can't believe I'm the one
defending our the nature of our schools
so we we know how to be good educators
and we know therefore that it is
possible for individuals to be good
educators but that does not mean that we
know how to do it system whine yeah I
think what I mean is something like
there is no excuse for us not to know
how to make a good school it's a totally
solving a problem if you set out the the
right objectives and then figure out
what works to meet them and you know you
and I have worked on an educational
project based on our 15 years of
experience at Evergreen and what we
concluded is that school should look
like you know exercises and games and
experiences that you don't even doesn't
feel like school things that teach to
you by virtually the fact that you want
to do them because they're fun right
that's what school should look like the
only argument for school should include
campfires school is a campfire extended
to a bunch of other realms so you know
the only excuse for having people sit in
chairs and face forward to hear somebody
talk and write the only excuse for that
is that it's economically efficient and
the fact is it's penny wise pound
foolish not to put together awesome
schools that make your population
incredibly smart because really what it
takes is just a developmental
environment that reinforces that stuff
that's what smart is no it's the
educational manifestation of Taylorism
it's how do you turn the Industrial
Revolution and the need for factory
workers into the production
of a population that is willing to do
that work yeah so I love John Taylor
Gatto um he reminds me that you know
we've got the let's burn it down camp
when it comes to school and school is
great camp and he's from the let's burn
it down but only after we get everybody
out of it yeah yeah that's right
I guess just one more thing that needs
to be said about school is that the
prospect of schools remaining closed
this fall especially if that includes
elementary school kids who are the most
at risk at home if they have bad home
lives means that some children may not
have an adult have had an adult eye on
them outside of their family for closing
in on a year and that the number of the
cases of abuse and worse are likely to
skyrocket sky rock for lots of because
the adults are more stressed the kids
won't have eyes on them yeah all kinds
of reasons so that is a huge danger one
of one of many in this case so I wanted
to just lay out the basics of what we
ought to be doing to get out of this
pickles and I actually think that school
is the thing that we should be shooting
for we should be shooting to be in a
situation where we can afford to open up
school on the far side of this okay and
so I mean it's very simple you need to
tell us that we're gonna lock down at
the maximum possible level for something
like six weeks right now obviously it
can't be a hundred percent you have to
be able to go to the hospital but by and
large if we had enough warning people
could stock up whatever financial
resources were necessary in order to
allow people to stock up could be
generated and then it's a question of
you know if you have spent time at the
beach you hold your breath and you go
under the wave right six weeks or
something of the maximum conceivable the
maximum plausible locked
that causes the virus to bounce whatever
routes it has and burn itself out for
the most part won't be a hundred percent
but it will be close right and then
intense testing and tracing on the far
end with with dealing with flare ups as
spot fires basically and I would say if
this can't be done at a national level
for some reason and frankly it was the
right thing to do months ago and it
remains the right thing to do even
though it's now harder then it is not
inconceivable to me at least that
individual states could decide to solve
their problem and the difficulty with
that is then they have to police their
borders right and that may not even be
constitutional because the nature of our
Federation is that citizens can move
freely between the states but at some
level if this is an epidemiological
crisis just the same way that crises
result in a modification of the way we
see your constitutional rights in
general we might have to do something in
a state that doesn't want to be dragged
down by a country that can't figure out
how to do a lockdown might decide you
know what we're gonna solve it in
Montana right we're gonna solve it in
Oregon and then I mean imagine the
following thing look folks on the right
typically are the ones advocating the
laboratory of the states is this great
idea I'm often skeptical of it because
of the bad game theory but imagine the
good game theory the race to the top
that emerges of a state figures out how
to solve this problem and suddenly that
state gets to go back to work right
imagine the advantage to the state that
figures out how to solve this problem
the kids get to go back to school the
workers get to go back to work the
economy fires up in this state that
state and the other states have to
follow suit so you know at some level
laboratory of the states is often a
catastrophe with respect to things like
taxes where we race to the bottom and
nobody can collect the taxes to do the
basic stuff but in this case it could be
race to the top and we should seriously
consider it alright this is a very long
pause yeah no I we've talked about this
and what I said earlier is
is true it's if it was too late then
it's even more too late now
and yet it's also true that I have the
extraordinarily human reaction of oh my
god no like we can't but I also know
that we won't
and that's mitigating my reaction which
is awful because the mitigation of the
reaction is just an understanding that
this is like politically not viable well
so here's the thing right it's still
summer in the in the northern hemisphere
and lockdown could mean go outside right
lockdown doesn't have to mean lockdown
in the winter look I think we got away
with something at the tail end of the
last cold season I guess I'm so if
lockdown we're smarter yeah right so you
know in I don't know if it's Portland or
all of Oregon again just because it's
the place where we live and so we know
best all the public swimming pools are
closed when there is again effectively
no or very little evidence that water
becomes infected when you swim in it and
that you can get co19 from swimming in a
pool even with someone who's infected
unless unless again it's it's airborne
at you and we we should be opening up
that stuff even as we and I guess
Newsome Gavin Newsome the Governor of
California has just as of yesterday may
be closed down all all bars again and
all indoor seating in restaurants you
know they did three counties in
California including the one that my
mother lives in were the first to close
down and anywhere in the US and
California locked down pretty
effectively shortly thereafter but then
they opened up and things went haywire
but they the entire thing was just this
half-assed mosaic of oh we're gonna
close down beaches why you're closing
down beaches what is wrong with you
people
yeah I can't close down the beaches
don't close down the pools don't close
down the nature areas don't close down
Columbia River Gorge many of the
waterfall waterfalls you can't go to
waterfalls it can be River Gorge still
this makes no sense so you can we can
say that at the same time that we can
say even though
I hate it we may just need more lockdown
but not dumb lockdown lockdown needs a
rebranding I have to tell you I've known
from the beginning that that term you
know it has this prison connotation and
it's got you know I don't know what the
right version of this is but the
northern hemisphere the sun is shining
we could do this such that we spend time
outside we check back in with stuff that
matters with family we could commune
over the internet I mean what a
marvelous tool this is if you're gonna
be locked down you can still talk to
people globe wide you know we have to
understand look we've got advantages
let's draw on them now and let's do what
needs to be done so we can drive this
thing to extinction because otherwise
we're just gonna be stuck with this
puzzle for who knows how long and
believe me you do not want to get this
thing and get better based on what that
looks like
yeah it's too dangerous yeah we pivot
sure right exactly an hour
okay well this might be one of the last
things we do no wrong okay my trackpad
just once again not really working
there we go Zack you want to just show
this so this was posted as a response to
your tweet of today's live stream Bret
mm-hmm okay so you know a version of
this this meme we've all seen for those
listening not watching you got the dude
whistling at a girl passing well the
young woman he's with is looking at him
and disgust and the dude is yang Yang
and the woman he's whistling at is a
progressive Republican and the woman
he's with but not looking at his
Democratic establishment I saw this so
you can take it down Zack I saw this and
I thought okay I've never heard the term
progressive Republican before but I
think that's what my dad was mmm I think
that's actually what my dad was and so
and I think it was episode six I talked
a bit about my dad it was the seventh
anniversary of his death I think
and I'm not gonna replay a lot of that
now but my dad never very close and we
love each other dearly and I never
understood his politics growing up my
parents tended to cancel out each
other's votes in presidential elections
my mother always voted Democrat my
father always voted Republican
my father voted for Reagan twice at the
end of his life he voted for Obama twice
and part of that was that he actually
you know he wasn't a conservative
through and through he was really a
progressive Republican and part of that
is that you know we you and I Brett got
together so young under 20 and that you
and I and my father spent a lot of late
evenings with bottles of wine talking
and and he moved you know he shifted
some he didn't he did not he you know he
dismissed you know I don't say our
perspectives if it was one perspective
but we were coming from roughly the same
same place and he dismissed it at first
and he definitely was one over to the
idea that we were on about something and
he also convinced us of a fair number of
things so I think there was a way in
which he had a kind of right of center
perspective that was born of a healthy
skepticism of solution making which is a
very important because solution making
which you only see the upside is just a
lethal hazard well he had seen it so
he'd grown up on a farm in northeastern
Iowa and he was born in 1938 and his his
father my grandfather was actually
elected as boy I remember what his
position was it was like county
commissioner or something that's I don't
think that's quite right but it was hit
and he was he was a Democrat mile time
was it was a Democrat and he if memory
serves the stories that I have heard I
heard from my father and also from my
Aunt Shirley that Harold my grandfather
would come home and complain about the
the ways that basically the the state
and the regulations were getting in the
way of his ability to do right by the
farmers whom he knew and in I think in
large part because of my father growing
up in that milieu seeing a functional
farm
dedicated patriot his father and
you-know-who himself as a lifelong
Democrat struggling against the
regulations that were imposed by people
who didn't know what they were doing my
father sort of swung over to the okay
well then we need to reduce regulations
side of things yeah he also just in his
professional life was I mean had no
prejudice right he was a mentor to
people in computer science who were
coding for the various projects that he
worked on and it was clear he didn't
care if you were woman or you're black
or didn't matter he just he took all
comers and it's so interesting you say
that because in none of this
conversation obviously I knew him so I
know that to be true but didn't even
occur to me that people would be
listening to this thinking as a publican
was probably racist like like no but
most people who are conservatives or
Republicans art well I agree but I mean
I'm stepping it back even a look lots of
people who I wouldn't call racist have
some prejudice they prejudge yeah right
and the basis of something any computer
science especially likely just well I'm
father was yeah especially likely as a
matter of sex and you know
you're the product of his not having
that prejudice right right because the
point was he you know it's not like he
was indifferent to the fact that you
were a girl but he certainly it didn't
change how he approached you
intellectually I had math brain he had
math brain and he taught me everything
sixth to calculus and you know we do my
elementary school homework and binary on
occasion so no didn't and I think you
know I think you took on what is
traditionally a more male mindset and I
think it's actually one of the reasons
that you do stuff like this so well is
that you're actually capable of seeing
things from different perspectives that
are often you know relegated to one side
of that line or the other but that was a
set of lessons largely instantiated in
and by my father yep yeah yeah it was
yeah so I bring him up in part because I
think you know I'd ever thought to call
him a progressive Republican but I would
just love to be hearing what he is
thinking about this moment and you know
he wouldn't have voted for Trump I know
that yeah um what would he be doing
right now you know I think he would be
excited about but skeptical of you ready
2020 yeah what is a wise position yeah
you know I'm it would be great if we had
him to bounce this stuff off of because
he would no doubt have interesting
insights about it so yeah yeah
progressive Republican is a good
description you know and maybe a bit of
head ahead of his time in that regard
yeah so is that it
do you want to say something about this
one last item before we it's so timely
yeah I think it makes sense
so hey Zach do you want to put up Barry
Weiss's better of resignation so well
zach is doing that we have two
announcements of of big names leaving
mainstream media this week we have
Andrew Sullivan leaving the New York New
York magazine
I think it's called although he will
explore some of his reasons for that
this Friday which I guess is gonna be
his last day and then Barry Weiss made
public her resignation letter from the
New York Times today and this is on her
website and we'll post that link as well
so it's an extraordinary letter it's an
extraordinary letter
I want to put it in a little bit of
context though the thing is okay so
Barry Weiss is a somewhat controversial
person at the New York Times but she has
left the New York Times and what she
does in her letter of resignation if she
describes the internal environment at
the Times right the ways in which her
license to explore things
journalistically that once existed has
been backed off by basically a
vindictive mob inside the times that
demonizes people publicly on their slack
channels and the like and the mob which
she believes to be a minority a minority
of the people yes because there's of
course the requisite culture of fear
that goes along with this so you have a
small number of very aggressive people
you have a large number of people who
can't say what they actually think it is
has effectively toppled The Times The
Times is not a news organization based
on what she says it is an organization
that is broadcasting a particular
perspective that you know we see in the
16:19 project and elsewhere yeah you
know the problem is not only does she
give us a window into what's going on at
the New York Times but we can infer from
what Matt Taibbi has said about what was
going on in other news rooms we can see
by Andrew Sullivan and what he is
apparently experiencing which we're
about to learn more about that there is
in the u.s. at least almost no and maybe
no journalistic establishment that is
not touched by this and that that is a
frightening prospect right to have an
inability for journalists to advance
certain mainstream perspectives because
a fringe has decided that those things
are intolerable is it is obviously a
prelude to the death of the Republic
either we figure out a way to reverse
that or there is no Republic you know
Benjamin Franklin's a republic if you
can keep it was a warning and we won't
be able to keep it if we can't talk
about what we actually think and
journalism is the place
this is supposed to be done at a high
high level so we're in dire straits and
I highly recommend that you read Barry
Weiss's letter I look forward to seeing
what Andrew Sullivan has said about his
departure and I guess stay tuned yeah
yeah well so we'll we'll take about a 15
minute break and then come back with Q&A
live stream will start with super check
questions from this one we're
prioritizing by monetary level and then
switch about half way through to super
check questions from the live stream
that we'll be doing then the QA and try
to take them in the order in which you
ask them just one more time you can find
a private discord server at both of
access tune-up both of our patreon
there's a clips channel our course clips
you can join Dark Horse membership at my
Patriot $5.00 level and up but can they
like and subscribe to the channel I
think they can they can like and
subscribe to the channel they can
comment that would be cool that would go
some feedback that's good you always say
that like I don't I don't look there so
I do you know I don't I don't read them
all but I do catch comments and they do
inform the way I think about things and
you know what else there's unity 2020 so
that seems like a good idea come find us
come find us on twitter at articles of
unity check out our website and stay
tuned if you sign up you're gonna see
the amazing stuff that we are gonna be
releasing this week I think you're gonna
be blown away
okay we're back in 15 minutes
you
[Music]